[Music]
foreign
view a first look at what is on the
front pages time then to see what is
making the headlines with the political
editor of the sun Harry Cole and the
political editor of the Daily Mirror
John Stevens welcome to both of you so
let's take a look shall we at the front
pages
starting with the Metro which leads with
the tragic events which occurred in
solihull the headline victims of ice
Lake after three young boys died after
falling into a freezing Lake
the tragedy beyond words is also
reported on the front page of tomorrow's
daily Express
the sum similarly carries the frozen
lake tragedy
and the mirror 2 rest in peace boys is
their front page
the times has the latest on the upcoming
nurses Strikers thousands of patients
will face cancellations after last-ditch
talks to avert them collapsed the
telegraph tells its readers that taxis
may be used as ambulances and Strikes
under plans being considered by
ministers that's to also making the
front of the eye they say the NHS will
block book taxis for patients in need of
non-critical hospital care
meanwhile the guardian draws attention
to a government report blaming the NHS
crisis on a Tory decade of neglect cold
weather and Road Chaos on the front of
the Daily Star as Frozen Brits are being
urged to cut their energy use in what
the paper is calling operation brass
monkeys The Daily Mail 2 calls out
frozen Britain as heavy ice brings the
country to a standstill
meanwhile the financial times covers the
latest on London's Stock Exchange after
Microsoft agrees to a 1.5
billion I think that's dollars or pounds
actually deal anyway after uh of a first
part of a 10-year strategic partnership
well a reminder that by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us so let's head straight to Our
Guest then where we're joined by Harry
Cole and John Stevens and uh straight to
the strikes we go Harry
um the times and other newspapers
picking up on the breakdown of those
talks between the Royal College of
Nursing and the health secretary and
what happened and why is there no deal
on the table for for nurses
a little slightly odd uh sort of fake
talks this afternoon where the health
secretary had said um you know there's
no there is going to be no budging the
offers on the table that's the offer
from the pay bodies but I'm happy to
have a chat coming for a cup of tea and
we'll we'll talk and the nurses have
said well if you actually talk properly
we'll be willing to spend the the strike
on Thursday
um if negotiations are reopened so they
sort of went through the motions of
talking today but actually it turns out
they they both went into the same room
said their pieces that they were saying
publicly all weekend it seems and then
came out and and the artist The Royal
College of nurses went very heavy on
Steve Barkley calling him belligerent
um and uh and Barclays people basically
said look I said I wasn't going to
renegotiate but I'm happy to talk so it
was a sort of fake Summit
um but yeah strikes are on tomorrow the
train service the rmt
um have said yep no our members back
here only by two-thirds I know a third a
third of members didn't vote for strike
action and interestingly unite who also
represent a very small number but a
number nonetheless of rail workers have
agreed to settle on that nine percent
over two year pay deal offered by
Network rails so the first sign of
cracks appearing in the in the unions
but uh the chaos is on regardless
tomorrow and more importantly I think on
Thursday yes and the mood music from the
government in terms of the nurses strike
at least is to shift it can
critical planning and ambulances to be
fair as well from any settlement or any
deal in this pay dispute so a number of
the newspapers picking up on what a
health Minister well Quint said about
block booking taxis to take certain
patients to hospital John
yeah so this is where Prince was up in
the Commons this afternoon and talking
about this is the end of the strike
which is due to take place next
Wednesday and talk about the different
kind of precautions that they've put in
place and so talking about how if people
aren't able to get an ambulance this is
for the kind of more minor cases this
isn't for things like heart attacks and
strokes this is if you kind of need
patient transport if you've got an
urgent problem but it's not
life-threatening then you might get a
taxi taking you to hospital I mean I
struggled to see that there's gonna be
that many taxis available to do these
jobs we know that taxis are at their
busiest at this time of year people go
into things like Christmas parties but
I think the whole government stance
today has been quite bizarre you had
Oliver Dowden who's the chancellor of
the duchy of Lancaster he chaired a
cobra meeting today afterwards he came
out and said that ministers would be
straining every sinew to minimize
disruption and then you see the nurses
saying if the government's willing to
have some sort of meaningful talks on
pay we will pause those strikes planned
for hospitals this week
and the government says no we're not
willing to have those talks and clearly
if they were straining every sinew they
would be willing to go in there and find
some sort of compromise and I think the
government has miscalculated on this one
at the start the strikes when it was
just the rare unions they seemed to be
really enjoying this they thought this
is where they could whack here's Dharma
over the heads and that's just the
spreading spread and spread I think that
the thing that people think is that the
country just isn't working and the
people they're blaming for that is the
government rather than the unions or the
labor party
and if you read uh the times going back
to that um the impact of all of this
beginning to be clear about 6 000
non-urgent operations are likely to be
canceled at the 45 hospitals in England
and Wells affected by Thursday strikes
up to 64 000 outpatient appointments
including MRI scans and cancer checkups
could also be called off and National
NHS Guidance the paper tells us says
patients need two days notice of
cancellations but because of the raw
mail strikes that means that hospitals
can't send letters notifying patients I
mean you couldn't make it up could you
Harry meanwhile the eye there talking
about the Army once again driving
ambulances many people pointing out that
some of those being called on to give up
their Christmas are paid less than some
of those going on strike um should we
require our military to step in in this
way
well there's there's some a process
called Maca where the military
assistance can be asked for by any
government Department it is always
controversial obviously in the time you
know in the covert during the vaccine
rollout
um some of the supermarkets watches I
think they got involved with at one
point driving lorries during the
pandemic I think there's a frustration
between sort of top brass that you know
the Army has sort of seen always there
is this contingency plan option that's
just always going to turn up and not
Grumble and do the job and I'm sure they
will turn up and not Grumble and do the
job
um but it is falling to sort of former
generals like so Peter wall I think was
out tonight little Danette was out
yesterday saying hang on these guys have
got four percent pay rise let's see what
what really belligerent and
unreasonableness looks like the the
nurses are asking for 19 pay rise even
kirst armor the man that can barely
bring himself to ever get off the fence
has said uh today that is unaffordable
and I and urge them to be a little bit
more reasonable in their discussions
with the government so it's not as quiet
as black and white as this idea that the
government just holding out the
government put an offer up you know on
the table through the independent pay
boards and they're they're basically
they can't if they give into one sector
they are going to have to give in to all
the sectors so they're in a sort of
tough position where they have to hold
the line on all of it take the Heat and
really trying to do contingency planning
now to try and alleviate the problems of
the strikes knowing that they're not
going to be able to divert the strikes
because if they give in to the rmt then
it's only going to bring other sectors
make them hold out for longer and make
them hold out for more but the nurses
really are on an outlier with that 19
request that even even the labor party
are saying come on that's a bit mad yes
and just quickly John um obviously in
Scotland nurses have accepted way less
than that 19 an average of 7.5 percent
uh with up to 11.2 for the bottom pay
bands that's been accepted it seems
strike called off there you know should
there be some wriggle room can the
should the government sniff that out
I think a lot of the Unions would be
willing to take some sort of compromise
they've shown that in Scotland I think
if the government was willing to show
some kind of ability to offer them a bit
more I saw a lot of people would say
they'd much rather take that than go on
strike I think it's quite interesting
particularly on ambulances that we've
had a lot more anger in the last couple
of days about the possibility that there
might be problems with ambulances on
strike days then we've had over the last
few months about the day-to-day state
with ambulances anyone who's had to call
an ambulance recently because they have
had a stroke or a heart attack knows
that the ambulances aren't being able to
get there in their kind of Target
response times and we've had nowhere
near as much angry about that than we've
had in the last few days about the
strikes
well let's move on shall we and it's
hard to do not to do these two stories
together which is the travel disruption
of Frozen Britain as the Daily Mail puts
it uh with the death of these three
young boys in this Lake in solihull you
know really brings home does it not that
the dangers of of icy water and that
message certainly coming through from
emergency services today Harry
yeah no just a horrific story that every
detail seems to get worse and worse they
were in hospital last night these
ballads and um you know and the News the
horrible news came through this morning
I think what's really jarring about this
story for me as well is the fact the
police are determined to carry on
searching because Witnesses and I
understand footage showed that there
could have actually been up to six young
people on that ice playing around in
that area that um that that afternoon
um they stressed that no one has come
forward to say anyone else is missing
but they seem very determined to make
sure they give that that Lake a proper
thorough and obviously a very hard thing
to do while the temperature's so low so
a very very Grim story in the sort of
outpouring of grief in that Community is
um it's very hard to watch yes and the
guardian uh picturing there some of the
firefighters who paid their respect at
the scene of the tragedy
um suggesting that the four boys were
reached by specialist water rescue
trained firefighters a police officer
had tried to to punch their way through
the ice and had mild hypothermia as a
consequence but an absolute tragedy is
the as the daily mail if we head back to
that John points out that um you know
our transport grinds to Halt and a
striking rail unions will selfishly pile
on the misery if I quote that that
headline
yeah I think there's a lot of Misery all
sorts of different ways of traveling in
the next few days in that story also
talks about motorways some people were
stuck on the M25 I think eight hours
last night you just think that you might
get stuck on some smaller roads but you
think if you're driving on the M25 you'd
be fine but also that absolutely
heartbreaking image of that little boy
their 10 year old Jack Johnson a lot of
the papers quoting his auntie posting on
Facebook saying that he didn't know the
other boys had fallen through the ice
but he went around to kind of go after
them to try and look after them and save
them and obviously died in the process
so an absolutely awful story as Harry
says well welcome back you're watching
the Press preview with me once again the
political editor of the sun Harry Cole
and the political editor of the Daily
Mirror John Stevens welcome back to both
of you um John let's go straight to the
Daily Telegraph and imminent we read
here a deal to speed up the return of
Albanian migrants tell us more
yes we can go heard all about the Rwanda
scheme where the government announced it
got loads of headlines it's meant to be
this great deterrence to stop people
crossing the channel but it wasn't a
talent at all because they didn't end up
sending anyone to Rwanda and this time
they've kind of decided on something
which sounds a lot more practical a lot
more workable sounds like wish you
sooner possibly as soon as tomorrow or
at least sometime this week is going to
announce uh Fast Track return schemes so
people crossing the channel who are from
Albania the government will be able to
send them back to about in baronia a lot
more quickly and we know that so far
this year I think it's about 44 000
people have crossed the channel about 12
000 of those so around about a third
have been Albanian and it's something
that the labor party were calling for
last week event Cooper was out there I
wonder if she may have had a whiff this
was something the government was about
to do so thought she would get ahead of
it by going out there and saying that
this is something that they should get
on with we know the around schemes at
the late party was very opposed to but
this one they say it's like things that
the late party did when Tony Blair was
in power they deem Albania was a safe
country they say that people crossing
from there should be sent back and then
they get a move on and start sending
them back we know that some of the
figures are around last week were
suggesting that just one percent of the
people who had come in the year to June
from Albania who put in an asylum
application it actually had it processed
and so this might be some way to kind of
clear the back clock and get on with it
yes and um let's move on to the times
and uh Harry and Megan the latest
installment you one of those who keenly
got up at eight o'clock last Thursday
morning to watch as many as you could I
think you managed two out of three I
can't believe you grasped me for that
he watched three out of three everyone
I just cannot believe uh everyone knew
he was going to sort of spill the beans
but he really really is going for it I
actually weirdly feel quite sorry for
Harry he's obviously the the trauma runs
quite deep and that relationship with
his brother I think now any type of
reconciliation about uh between those
two must surely be you know far far far
away you know in a different age a
different time you know royal families
have you know gone to war gone to war
for less than some of the things that
that Harry and William has thrown at
each other so it is a horrible situation
I think um I think it's beginning to
backfire on on on the sussexes I think
some of that uh impersonation of Megan
kurtzing in front of the queen
pretending she didn't know what she was
doing and generally mocking the royal
family at a time when you know the king
is still you know the king of the
country is still in mourning for for the
late monarch
um talk about 10 Aid so um tune in for
more tinnitus next Thursday